welcome everyone to what's going to be a
kind of an experimental video a few
hours ago I played a local tournament at
the St Louis chess club it was a weekly
quad event and in one of my games I
played a good friend of mine I am Kosta
karutski of chastojo you can check out
his amazing content link will be below
we played a very instructive and
hard-fought Rapid game and I filmed the
whole thing and I have the game video of
the game on one laptop on another laptop
I have the game itself and what I'm
gonna do is some voice over kind of
pseudo live commentary of the game I
haven't done this before I really hope
that you enjoy it hopefully it makes for
good content if you like it let me know
in the comments let me know if you want
to see more of this but let's hop in to
the game
so I will say I did a little bit of
preparation for him beforehand and I
knew I was gonna play E4 and try and
trick him into a sicilian that he would
be less comfortable with I started with
Knight C3 which
I've played over the years actually gave
a lecture a few years ago for the St
Louis chess club on how to win with
Knight C3
and then I play Knight F3 so I'm keeping
the option open of transposing into an
open Sicilian but he stops that with
Pawn E5
and I play Bishop to C4
and we're entering
A variation which I had a little bit of
knowledge but I hadn't reviewed recently
so I was kind of on my own from a
preparation standpoint but I still knew
some basic ideas
and the move I just played Knight D2
we're gonna see the point of after G6
Knight to F1
I spend several moves moving my Knights
but the idea is now I'm controlling this
very weak D5 Square inbox position now
Kush is unfazed I'm sure he's aware that
this is still some opening Theory
and we're still in some I think known
territory
I played Knight D5
and this is basically where my my
knowledge of the position ends but I put
my Knights on the nice output square and
I know I have ideas of Pawn to F4 at
some point
but black is very very solid
apart from the D5 Square it's really
hard to find any like major weaknesses
in box position and from here it's going
to be a fight so he plays King H7 which
is a very logical move getting the king
off the diagonal of my lights red bishop
and with this move he is very much ready
to play Pawn to F5
and this is where I take my first kind
of extended think of the game trying to
figure out the best approach for whites
and I decide to go for Pawn to F4
essentially not wasting any time with
other moves but trying to open up the
king side in some sense uh the rook and
Bishop support the pawn
I wanted to make it so black would maybe
have some difficult decision to make of
course there's tension between the Pawns
and I wasn't entirely sure what to
expect from kushti here
but he decided to take which did
surprise me a little bit because this
allows me to very simply recapture with
my bishop and develop my final minor
piece into the game
oh no my focus apologies for the focus
issues I was recording with my iPhone
yeah so I was feeling pretty good here
but after 95 black has clear intentions
of removing this bishop and maybe just
getting the bishop hair he's also
blocking my dorkscrew Bishop from
attacking D6 now I simply move back to
B3 maintaining the bishop pair
and again I was feeling like very
comfortable I think white has like
really nice piece Harmony
but black still has a stable position
and Costa was taking his time
now you'll see me glance briefly at the
author game because the two other
players were in our same quad and I I
was gonna play them in the subsequent
rounds so I was making a mental note of
what opening was happening in their game
yeah very quickly I had to refocus on my
game
and Costa plays F5 which is a very
energetic move
but the idea not only is now that Rook
is trying to get involved basically
similar ideas from when I played Pawn F4
he wants to have a trail in F5 so the
bishop or Knight can activate but he
also has an idea here of playing G5 and
if my Bishop Retreats then F4
now I decided to play Queen D2 and keep
all the tension in the position
and I was very much aware that G5 is a
possible move for black
and we can see
Costa deliberating here
now he has spent a little bit more time
early in the game
I'm up about a minute on the clock now
with Queen D2 I'm just trying to make
all my pieces happy the queen and Bishop
now have a battery directed towards each
six and my Rook is ready to come to E1
so I'm just trying to get ready for for
the position maybe opening up even more
especially with the pawn tension
now Costa does play G5
attacking the bishop
and this put me in a slightly awkward
position because if I move my Bishop
back to E3 or G3 I get hit with F4 and
black is getting a lot of space there
with initiative the bishop drops back to
F2 in those cases there would be Knight
G4 and I was already like fearing Knight
takes G4 and Bishop D4 so I was trying
to figure out my alternative in this
position
and it was a critical moment so I was
taking
a bit of time
now the candidate moves I had were of
course the bishop Retreats I very
briefly considered Bishop takes G5
But ultimately I decide for Knight takes
E7 which is a nice in-between move
because now if black takes the bishop
I'm happy to take on F5 with the knights
and white would be coming out on top in
that line
and Costa considered this briefly
I mean pretty soon he realized he has to
take the knights
I was surprised he took
this long to make the recapture
but once he does I get more initiative
I'm leaving my Bishop attacked by the
pawn because I'm just making bigger
threats hitting the queen he drops back
to d8
and now I'm actually still in the same
predicament I have to decide what to do
with my Bishop
do I Retreat do I concede the bishop
pair and take on E5
and we're gonna see but one of the
reasons why I went for the trail in E7
to put my other Knight on D5 is after I
trade on an E5
I no longer have a knight on C3 so when
he takes with the bishop
I play Pawn C3
and even though I can see that the
bishop pair
my knight is really happy and this
bishop is actually somewhat restricted
because now there's ideas of D4 there's
no attack against B2
it might look scary that the Bishops
aimed towards each two
but uh it's not really a great way for
black to add any attackers to the king
side
so coaster again takes a bit of a think
and I was feeling good here like even
though I
can see that the bishop hair
my knight is so powerful on D5 it's just
a long-term Outpost
and if the bishop were effort to trade
for the knights my Bishop would land on
D5 which would also be a powerful piece
so he opted for Pawn takes Pawn
now crazily enough the engine in this
position will find an engine move engine
says Queen E3 is winning I didn't
consider that I took back which I think
is like the most natural move
sometimes in Rapid chess it can be easy
to make these automatic captures
and not consider other options in a
position like that
and the reason why he took on e4 is now
this Pawn is isolated so I don't have
these D4 ideas
and this bishop is actually very stable
now on E5 it's very very hard for white
to ever remove the darks per Bishop
essentially because I don't have a
dartsford bishop of my own
so here Costa takes a bit of a think I
might speed up the video to just get to
the point where he moves but we can see
based on the time situation things are
looking nice for me I'm up almost three
minutes on the clock
Bishop D7 is played which is a logical
move eventually aiming to get the Rook
involved from eight
and I don't think he played Bishop E6
because he was probably worried about
like Rook Cafe and knights seven ideas
in Bishop D7 maybe he's aiming for
Bishop to C6
so here I take somewhat of a think
because even though my pieces are
decently placed
it's still a matter of coming up with a
plan for whites
and I was trying to figure out how to
further improve the position
and sometimes the question to ask
yourself in a position like this
is which piece can be improved
and I actually decided that my Knights
could be improved even though it looked
good on D5 it wasn't actually doing that
much
and it was blocking my bishop and my
queen both of which are now Unleashed
and with Knight E3 I have the idea of
Knight to F5 with potential really nice
Outpost Square supported by the pawn and
The Rook
so I'm still trying to make gradual
improvements
he plays Queen to E7
which is a solid looking move
connecting the Rooks
going for
Rook 88 most likely
and now I took another bit of a think
because I was really wanting to play
Knight F5
but I was trying to assess the
transformation that would likely happen
because if I play Knight F5 black can
take with the bishop
and then assuming I take back with the
pawn
a lot of things have changed where then
it becomes an officer Bishop situation
I was trying to figure out if there's
any chances for white to still be better
there because obstacle Bishops have a
tendency of being drawish
now there are other options for white in
this position I could leave the Knight
on E3 and maybe play a move like G3 or
Rook D1
I do eventually play Knight to F5
kosha very quickly takes
and we're going to see the the rapid
game is quickly turning in to a Blitz
game
both of us falling lower on time
Now by taking back with the pawn
I do a lot of things for one I do get a
defended pass Pawn on F5
I'm also looking to control the E6
square but then coaster plays a very
annoying looking move Bishop to F4
simultaneously attacking the queen and
blocking my Rook from defending the F5
Pawn we should note F5 is not capturable
because Bishop C2 but he's trying to
weaken F5 and create a situation where
he can't capture it
now I had seen this position coming and
originally I was going to play Queen D3
but once we got to this position I
realized I have another option
and you can see me contemplating here
but it turns out I don't have to move my
queen
there's a really interesting
counter-attack
that white can play where I just leave
my queen on D2 I play Rook ae1
counter-attacking blocks Queen
and during the game I had a feeling that
Costa maybe overlooked this move because
sometimes when you attack your
opponent's Queen you expect it to just
move away
but with this move I make a situation
where if black takes my queen
I'll take on E7 with check and then I'll
be winning the B7 Pawn
so black has to move away goes to plays
Queen to G7
and now I can happily move my queen
I was debating where to move it I mean
D5 was an option and D3 I think these
were the two main moves I was debating
between now I play Queen D3 setting up
Pawn F6 check so maybe get some tactics
if a pawn F6 would allow Queen G6 I
think Costa did not want any of this
and for that reason he plays Rook to F6
simply blockading the pawn
and then I play Bishop to E6
having a really nice Construction in
Black's territory by Pawn defends a
bishop the bishop defends upon and
because of the officer Bishop situation
it's very difficult for black to ever
remove the pawn or the bishop without
sacrificing material
so he essentially has to play around
these pieces for the next many many
moves I play Queen D5
and we can see things kind of closing
down like I'm trying to to further
optimize my pieces
Queen D5 blockade Z6 pressures B7
I also had ideas of potentially sacking
on E5 thought maybe that would be the
eventual way to make progress a coaster
plays V4 which I think is a nice
practical move
he's trying to create some opportunity
on the king side maybe you get some Pawn
storm maybe he got in G3 I did have to
be careful about my king becoming a
Target on G1
and we can see my time advantage
is still there but it's dissipating with
every second that ticks away
no longer up over a minute on the clock
I'm falling below three minutes
I was just trying to figure out a plan
here position is so closed
and this construction for black is quite
stable I play rookie four
he plays Pawn H5
so I was trying to pressure the fourth
rank yeah I can only do so much
so I play Rook D1 I'm really trying to
set up some eventual sacrifice my dream
was to play Queen C4 Rook E5 and then
Rook D7
but after Rook f8
and Bach is just being solid
in positions like this can sometimes be
frustrating because
on one hand
positions very nice white should be
better
but at the same time it's hard to figure
out a way to make progress
for Costa he's just chilling he's just
kind of waiting for what my plan will be
and very soon we're going to see my
whole time advantage
disappear
yeah I'm officially down on time
and sometimes this is one of my
weaknesses online chess and over the
board chess
where I'll just let my times drain and
sometimes these positions just call for
quick moves Ghost Ship plays B6 I play
A4
I realize that if I'm gonna make
progress It's probably on the queen side
I have ideas of maybe eventually A5 even
B4
he plays Rook H6
and now I was realizing that the
position is not that simple on the
king's side because now there's ideas of
Pawn H4
I have to be really careful about the
structure crumbling and my king getting
very unsafe
so I was looking for a way to
try and tame his attack
but I don't have much time to think
sometimes when I get low on time and I
get nervous
I start blinking a lot
but every time I blink
I usually think it leaves one move ahead
so I play King G2 I figured my king is
better
on a light Square so this bishop can't
touch it
kosher plays King h8 essentially for the
same reason my Bishop can't touch the
black king
sorry kings are on slightly safer
squares
but my time is still ticking I fall
below a minute
and in my mind I'm telling myself
what to do
but that thought process doesn't really
help
so okay I played Queen to G4
which essentially stops a pawn from
moving because I create the battery
against the g-pawn
so I was just trying to hold my ground
and keep
the position stable
kosha plays Queen B7 nice geometrical
move
transferring the queen to the queen side
pinning my Rook on e4
so now my queen is tied down
and I have to be very careful not to
blunder anything simple
now of course I have a move like Bishop
D5 and maybe repeat but I go for Pawns
of B4 I'm really trying to break through
here
I figure that there's no threat with a
pin and any time I want I can play
Bishop to D5
and with Pawn B4
I'm just trying to open some file on the
queen side and maybe take advantage of
the fact that in some cases as d-pawn
can be overworked
now Kush Is Falling below a minute
and there's still so much tension so
much life left in the position
and what started as a rapid game is now
very quickly turning into a bullet game
Costa plays Pawn A6
which looks like an innocent waiting
move maybe preparing Pawn to B5
I play Queen D5 offering a queen trade
now there was a two second increment so
very soon you're going to see both of us
just surviving on the increments
I figured that due to the time situation
it'd be easier to play without Queens on
the board
and Costa takes
I hesitate for a moment I take with a
rook
and now Rook H7 now the game next to us
is getting exciting but I have no time
to watch it because I have to focus on
my own game
I'm below 10 seconds I play Pawn A5
trying to weaken the queen side
and here we're going to see the queen
side just explode I lose C3 I win B6
I lose B4 I win D6
Rook be trying to tame my past Pawn
I play Rook C4 A5
now Rook C7 trying to make some Headway
Pawn A4
I play Bishop C8 sneaky move
A3
and all of a sudden Rook d8
checkmates a very abrupt ending
to what was just a kind of crazy finish
and we can see the game next to us also
having a crazy finish
it turns out that
Bishop C8 was a completely winning move
for whites just to show some quick
analysis
if Rook takes on C7 I would happily take
back and then rooksia is met with Rook
d8
and this is completely winning for
whites
otherwise I believe Rook A8
is met with Bishop to B7 the pawns are
just too slow and white is queening so
it's a very crazy game
uh I really haven't had a chance to
analyze so much with engine but I will
leave a link to the game and let me just
study so if you want to analyze it feel
free to do so and let me know your
thoughts about this video format let me
know if you want to see more content
like this I'm very much open to
suggestions for improvements so thanks
so much for watching if you like this
subscribe and stay tuned for more
content